how about everyone welcome to today's
live broadcast measurement assurance for
tissue engineering and regenerative
medicine I'm Kristina jeweled elaborate
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events today's educational seminars
presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider a virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning for more information please go
to ww Bruce calm now we have a feelin
horny now since people are we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to get
to as many questions as we can you can
in life water to the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearings presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem through degree in Q&A button on
the lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Carl Simon dr. Simon is a biologist in
the biomaterials group at the National
Institute of Standards and Technology he
aims to develop reliable pools and
standards for measuring the properties
of cells biomaterial scaffolds and
tissue engineered construct a
regenerative medicine moves from a
research endeavor to a viable industry
that Memphis patients and US Commerce
reliable methods for assessing product
consistency and quality are required in
one of his projects he's working with
cocktail party and I eight to establish
simple robust methods for characterizing
tissue-engineered retinal pigment
epithelium for use in a clinical trial
to treat age-related macular
degeneration in another product keep
working with Pamela Roby NIH to improve
dancing and measurements of osteogenesis
induced by stem cell scaffold
formulations in an ectopic phone
mouse model he also worked with computer
science scientists to develop image
analysis and bioinformatics methods for
assessing the physical properties of 3d
tissue scaffolds and how they include
cell function dr. Simon is chair of ASTM
Committee 404 point 43 cells and tissue
engineered constructs for documentary
standards are being developed to support
the development of tissue-engineered
medical product here the BS in biology
from Bucknell University and a PhD in
biochemistry from University of Virginia
where to speed this focus on signal
transduction during human platelet
aggregation he trained as a postdoctoral
fellow in nift polymers division and
became a scientist at nift in 2003 dr.
Fineman is active in a society for
biomaterials ISO hummus and facilitate
and in on an editorial board for
biomaterials and journals biomedical
materials research part be applied
biomaterials I'd like to turn the
presentation now over to dr. Fineman
[ __ ] assignment thank you thanks
elaborate thanks to starving Christina
for this opportunity to talk about
measurement insurance I work at the
national institute of standards and
technology which is in Gaithersburg
Maryland our mission is to promote
innovation and industrial
competitiveness in the United States by
advancing measurement science standards
and technology we were established in
1901 we have about 5,000 staff 3,000 of
which are PhD in for nobel laureates
this is a view of the campus from the
air and the yellow outline is an outline
of the campus it's about two miles
across and about a six mile perimeter
the road on the right there 272 familiar
with ritu 70 we're about 20 miles north
of washington DC our budget last year
was about 1 billion
dollars and we were stablished by
Congress in 1901 so quick outline
basically I'm going to cover the
concepts of metrology through the lens
of tissue engineering and regenerative
medicine so I'm going to give you the
talk about a little bit about
documentary standards on this footprint
and precision medicine measurement
assurance truth and talk about an inter
laboratory study a colleague of mine did
and then I'm going to talk about a
measuring chart and your learning
objectives all focused on aspects of
metrology that you might pick up during
the talk so since this is a precision
medicine webinar I wanted to talk
briefly about myths footprint here so
for precision medicine to work whereby
new diagnostics and precision-guided
therapies will come to market we're
going to need good measurements that are
accurate and reproducible on the key to
precision medicine is going to be sound
data for robust clinical decision making
and this is sort of missed bread and
butter we have a long history developing
products that support measurements and
sound decision making and as well as
clinical measurements and healthcare so
three example genomic reference material
one is purified or one of them is
genomic reference materials which will
purify DNA there's five of them you see
them listed down there rm8 398 and the
five below that and these are full
genome sequences from five individuals
and their highly well characterized so
that when you use one of these in your
sequencing platform you can assess how
well you're doing so these if you will
will serve as a truth or a check or a
calibration point for your sequencing
another one is Miss monoclonal antibody
rm8 671 which is an antibody which you
can get from this and it's been highly
characterized for a number of key
attributes that are critical for protein
therapeutics such as slight consolation
and amount of substance that's right
here
another one is the knitter to reference
material and this is purified DNA from
five breast cancer cell lines with
different amounts of her2 amplification
again you would use these if you're
making measurements of her to to make a
clinical decision obviously her choose a
good one to focus on because it was one
of the first precision medicine products
where you had a diagnostic kit
accompanying a treatment and if you want
to know how well you're measuring her to
copy number you can run your tests on
the NIST reference material to get a
sense of how well you're performing so
those are some basic products that NIST
has developed to benefit healthcare in
the precision medicine area so I'm going
to back up a little talk more broadly
and generally about measurement science
and metrology so why do we collect data
why do research why conduct an
experiment the number one commonality is
you want to make some comparisons you
want to make a decision so you collected
you want to collect data and compare
things and then make a decision about a
course of action so how do you assure
that your data are reliable that they're
trustworthy inter suitable for their use
that's what metrology is how do you do
that how do you assure that so I'm going
to talk about biological measurement how
to make these more quantitative and
reliable in terms of regenerative
medicine and tissue engineering so
generally speaking there's been quite a
bit of concern over reproducibility in
biological measurements there's some
headlines here you can see their report
of this landmark paper in 2011 where
they were only able to reproduce twenty
one percent of the literature
experiments that they had tested for
drug leads and then another team down
there on the bottom left found that they
could only confirm results in eleven
percent of studies think some of that
work was from and jen and there's other
ones on the right there so there's just
general concern about the lack of
produced ability in biological
measurement to sort of underpinned
missed work here and will be key to
overcome for precision medicine so when
you talk about precision medicine
regenerative medicine frequently comes
up which is why there's a regenerative
medicine track here I think in in many
precision medicine suppose you'll find
there is a regenerative medicine track
and that's generally because
regenerative medicine includes using
cells or auto auto log of cell therapies
when developing a therapeutic where
you're going to use somebody sells
you're going to modify them somehow and
then use them to treat that person on
this is an overview of you if you will
of the evolution of Medicine starting
with surgery than small molecule drugs
and devices and then protein
therapeutics which which sort of started
in the 80s and now we have cell therapy
and gene therapy there's been a lot of
work in gene therapy and I think law one
product has come to market and then in
cell therapy depending on who you talk
to you maybe 30 products have come to
market this is an exciting area because
in a cell therapy or a regenerative
medicine approach you're typically
treating the root cause of a disease or
a pathology or trauma not a symptom
because you're trying to repair the
tissue that's faulty so this is a
snapshot of regenerative medicine and
why this is a good focus area for nifty
us is in health care costs prices where
we're spending eighty percent of our gdp
on healthcare which is fifty percent
more than switzerland which is second on
the list and whenever they spend twelve
percent some major targets for tissue
engineering include musculoskeletal and
diabetes musculoskeletal by some
estimates accounts for six percent of
u.s. gdp this is 850 billion per years
of towards musculoskeletal and it's
estimated that half of all people in the
US have a musculoskeletal disorder
diabetes also a big one specting six
million patients and
consuming approximately one percent of
the gdp so cost effective treatments for
these obviously could have good economic
outcomes the United States there's
approximately as i mentioned 30 products
on the market and regenerative medicine
to the big ones or skin equivalents and
articular cartilage replacements there's
estimated to be 700 companies and 600
clinical trials underway so the Alliance
to regenerative medicine and the
regenerative mountain regenerative
medicine foundation published 22 surveys
which were quite eye-opening for us at
NIT the Alliance regenerative medicine
survey looked at fourteen pharma
companies you can see them there and
they they asked some questions one of
them was why don't you invest more in
regenerative medicine and one of the
conclusions was that product consistency
and lack of standards was possibly the
single greatest challenge facing the
field it was it was a major deterrent
for these big varmints when investing
more in this sector regenerative
medicine foundation reached a very
similar conclusion in a workshop that
they held in 2015 where they concluded a
lack of reference materials to benchmark
measurements in validation criteria for
critical assays the biggest roadblock
Phillips to the field a consortium led a
few consorcio sore to do some
roadmapping and on this is the summary
figure from the roadmap there you can
see it's a title page on the left you
can see control technology cell
attribute testing measurement
technologies standardization regulatory
for support these made it onto the front
summary figura growth of the report
again highlighting how this is essential
to the success for a regenerative
medicine is better measurements and
measurement infrastructure so I want to
talk now about documentary standards
where these fit in there's a lot of
organizations involved in developing
documentary standards i'm personally
involved in many of them
ASTM in I so I keep an eye on us p @
keep an eye on VIP em I already
mentioned Alliance for generative
medicine they're involved over there not
a standards development organization
I've been involved with hefty I keep an
eye on fact so I try to keep an eye on
all these make sure we don't have
overlapping things that are happening as
well as my colleagues do the same what
we try to avoid overlap and duplication
streamline activities in these I'm going
to focus now on what we typically mean
when we say standards to mean different
things to different people so we
typically need documentary standards
which are written documents there's
typically ten pages long that they can
be longer or shorter they're written by
working groups of subject matter experts
in a standards development organization
and FBO if you will they typically
include a broad spectrum of people
academic researchers government
personnel industry and then users and
users would be like a surgeon or a
dentist they're the ones that we need
practitioners that you will they usually
require a vote to pass and they're often
conceived as consensus they're really
not consensus we would like him to be
consensus but it's nearly impossible
consensus means everybody agrees usually
not everybody agrees but most of the
times we can get good agreement among
most of the stakeholders they take a law
to develop they're usually two to five
years some can take longer some I've
seen them in a year standards can have a
negative connotation they can some
people say you know they're restrictive
I can't innovative I have to follow this
standard went that's not really true
generally speaking standards are out
there that promote innovation there's
this saying you can't improve something
if you can't measure if you can't make a
good measurement on to things and
compare them apples to apples as you
will it's hard to say which one is
better or if any changes you've made are
causing an improvement so we would argue
that standards promote innovation
and then this anxiety comes because
somebody may be doing some work where
the standard is not a perfect fit in
that case the standard may not may not
be relevant and you wouldn't have to
necessarily have to follow it or you can
invent your own test methods for new
technologies this happens all the time
so there's two main types of
documentary's standards guides and test
method guides are sort of general advice
on an area or a measurement in their
items that you would want to consider
when you're conducting a measurement a
test method be more detailed where you
get down in the weeds on one particular
measurement and talk about all the
nitty-gritty details of how to conduct
that measurement in this usually
involves an interlaboratory tough where
several labs thought the measurement by
following the protocol to see if they
can get acceptable agreement and this
would be called comparability so when a
standard exists for a measurement that
you're interested in you should consider
yourself lucky because this is going to
save you a lot of time this means that
this measurement is embedded in several
labs and people agreed that it was a
good measurement and they could get good
agreement and that means you can start
with that protocol on your own lab and
save yourself all the time and hassle of
an assay development so in ASTM we have
336 voting members on committee fo for
which is tissue engineered medical
products so when these standards come to
pass 336 people either voted or abstain
typically about a hundred people will
vote and the rest will abstain depending
on their expertise it so there's a lot
of different types of standards that are
getting voted on and people when it's
not in their their area of expertise
though abstain but usually about 80 to
100 people vote on each one positive or
negative and all negatives have to be
considered if you get a vote that's
negative this has to be discussed
amongst the committee generally speaking
what happens is modifications are made
to appease the negative vote and there's
usually discussion between the negative
voter and the committee most of the time
and everyone that I've been involved in
we found a resolution there are cases
I've heard where a resolution cannot be
found and that will go to vote whether
or not this team persuasive or not
persuasive it's not persuasive then the
negative vote may be ignored but as I
said I've not seen that happen in the
ones i've been involved with and at ASTM
we have several voting classes general
interest producer user and we like the
number of general interest and users to
equal the number of producers and this
tries to keep a balance between the
voters so you don't have someone that
may have a conflict of interest one way
or the other pushing a document room
this is a portfolio of standards in ASTM
fo for for three cells and tissue
engineers you can skim over a few the
titles there you can see one down them
number for standard god for quantitating
cell viability within biomaterial
scaffold that one just came up for
renewal you can see we have a couple
down there on the bottom there under
development these are living documents
that renew by vote every five years and
there was drawn when they become off the
leader displaced by better technology
and they can be revived at any time
followed by those i'm going to zoom in
on that 2739 we just renewed that one
last year it's about seven pages covers
about twenty methods for measuring cell
viability it gives a great discussion of
each to the principles of the
measurement and their assumptions and
highlights the number of known issues
usually give they give a few we give a
few recommendations and tips for each of
the measurements and as a novice this is
a great starting place you're going to
you have a medical product regenerative
medicine product you want to measure
toxicity when i measure cell adhesion
you want to measure viability in your
scaffold these are good starting place
to measure these cell viability
measurements get an overview of what's
out there and
the advantage is that this has been
vetted by a working group of experts and
voted on you can get a review from the
literature which could also be helpful
but the ASTM standards or iso standards
or wherever you might find your
standards on a particular topic has been
vetted by a working group which makes
them more reliable if you're an expert
they may not be a great use to you but
they do provide a credible overview of
viability measurements and it gives you
confidence you're aware of what you
think you're aware of because if you
read the document is boring to you and
you know everything in the document but
that's good that means you you knew
everything that that committee new
thought was important enough to put in
that document that gives you confidence
moving forward you can also use it as a
citation when you're following your
review to FDA so now I'm going to get a
bit more philosophical talk about
measurement assurance so assurances the
state of being certain about something
and measurement assurance as well as
follow is a process to ensure that you
have confidence in your measurements
when you measure something what you're
measuring is typically called the
measure rant and see that down the page
there and the definition is the quantity
intended to be measured and that is the
word intended is interesting because
that's intentional because there's a lot
of artifacts in making a measurement you
can be confused and misled by your
measurement through false positives or
false negatives so you may not be
measuring what you think you're
measuring and that's why the word
intended is used in that definition an
example with me and you want to measure
the postie of a cell therapy product you
might measure cell viability cuz you're
saying cell viability is related to the
potency you might measure try cantaloupe
booth exclusion which is a measure of
cell membrane leakiness and you might
find that the results don't correlate
with potency this could happen for
another number of reasons that may be
that the membrane leakiness is a late
stage indicator of viability and
maybe the cells are losing their potency
earlier in the death process or maybe
live cells are required to your
mechanism of action may be injecting the
cell causes an immune response which
mediates the mechanism of action for
your regenerative medicine product and I
mentioned me too because people to come
up and cut our conversation all the time
when we talk about cell therapy products
and regenerative medicine and tissue
engineering I'm trying to figure out
what it is you're measuring what are the
false positives and what are the false
negatives and one of the assumptions
associated with your measurement that's
where the is were distended come from
the quantity intended to be measured so
the bipm has published the vocabulary in
two naps Janelle's and metrology which
was written in Paris than International
Committee and my colleagues has taken
three definitions from this marks ow he
calls me the three-legged stool of
metrology and certainty traceability and
validation so uncertainty is the
dispersion of your measurement result if
you have if you make two single
measurements on two different things you
may not be sure how to compare them you
don't know how good these results are
but if you make many measurements and
get a dispersion you can get an
uncertainty on these and this helps you
to compare these results without the end
13 without it making multiple
measurements and getting a dispersion of
your measurement results you don't know
how how much air is associated with your
measurement and you can't draw any
conclusions soin 30 is key for a good
comparison and making a decision
traceability is the property of a
measurement where you can trace it back
to some common reference length is a
good one because we all agree on the SI
units and the length of a meter and when
you get a ruler and make a measurement
you know that's traceable back to some
standards somewhere that defines how
long a meter is there's a picture there
of the u.s. meter 27 which was made in
Paris and given to the US and 1893 and
served as the official u.s. meter from
the 1893 2 1960
of course we don't use that anymore we
have other ways to define what a meter
is but the initial thing artifact
validation is the provision of objective
evidence that a measurement is adequate
for its intended use so does it work for
what you need it to work for in the
picture there you can see the lumberjack
trying to cut down a tree with a kitty
cat which doesn't work but to chainsaw
work that's sort of a comical view of
validation some other key terms or
lingos fit for purpose quality systems
are focused on validation invalidation
helps you to identify critical
parameters to control so validation
would be we conduct an extra
measurements to collect information
other information to determine whether
or not the information that you've
gathered is what you think it is so
running controls for the way to validate
your results so I want to talk about a
couple measurement surance success
stories one is cholesterol it was
discover that cholesterol correlated
with heart disease and so people became
interested in measuring this is a
clinical indicator you can see on the
left there that we have a lot of false
positives and negatives leading to
wasted money and people having heart
attacks then we began developing
reference materials first a pure
cholesterol reference material this is
in 67 this serves as controlling you
make a cholesterol measurement so you
can know whether you're getting the
right answer then we've realized that
theorem interferes with the cholesterol
measurement so another reference
material is issues just cluster Owens
here on us because you measure
cholesterol here and the proteins get in
the way of the measurement and your
measurements are it's accurate so we
came out with other reference materials
where the cholesterol had been measured
very well in a serum reference material
and over the years this has led to a
reduction in the number of false
positives and false negatives and we
have greater confidence that our
measurements of cholesterol now
which is like a lot of savings and
quality of life improvement for the the
u.s. in the world another one is hba1c
which is an indicator of diabetes some
clinical trials linked it to diabetes
and so people started measuring it as an
indicator of diabetes you can see in the
pot there the data points are in noisier
when you measure see they're measuring
different epitopes the measurement
infrastructure wasn't well defined the
protocols more well-defined there
weren't reference materials so people
began developing reference material
standard protocol certification programs
and the one standard episode was agreed
upon so over to the right 2010 you can
see it in your lab study between
different labs you can see there's much
better agreement and now on a clinician
sends off your blood for an hba1c
measurement they get back the result
that's more comparable to the results in
the clinical trial and other labs you
have greater confidence in your
diagnosis so we were in a workshop that
mr. 2015 with the number of regenerative
medicine stakeholders and we came up
with this wheel really it was a brick
wall that you change it to a wheel and
it's sort of each one of the spokes on
this wheel or to a little blue circles
as a reference is a measurement
assurance strategy I'm not going to go
through all of them but if you look at
some of them you can see reference
material which I talked about I don't
think we've touched on and user what
other ones in there increasing and
increasing replicas is a good way to of
your measurements is a good way to
improve confidence automation over
versus having human conduct processes
automation can you approve precision so
you get better results process controls
or steps in things you measure during
your measurement to make sure things are
working like if you list cells off of a
plate you look at them in the microscope
to make sure that all the cells are
listed off
that would be sort of a process control
performance specification establishing
those for your measurements so if I
measure a background I don't get point
05 on my plate reader or within some
range around point 05 and I know
something's wrong that would be a
process control or performance
specification so if you don't get a good
background signal too high or too low
maybe the light sources wearing out
maybe your plates misaligned these are
specification to help you determine
whether to keep or use your data
inter-laboratory study we discuss the
little businesses when you pass out
samples amongst labs and success how
comparable results can be when you have
all these together were not necessarily
all of them but when you have a good
measurement then you can get a protocol
that can be validated and you can see
that arrow pointing down to the bottom
leads to a documentary standard I swear
standards come in and that would be
after some of this hard work has been
done up front to improve the quality of
an asset so you can get a documentary
standard you can see this in the
flowchart you don't necessarily need a
documentary standard you can go from a
validated protocol over to the right
there which was making your decision the
documentary's standard would be more if
you want to help us help us communities
so a community like regenerative
medicine where people are struck all
struggling with similar topics the
documentary standard can help the other
stakeholders in this state so reference
material item guide 35 defines a
reference materials something
sufficiently homogenous and stable with
us with respect to a specific property
homogeneous is stable or key meaning
Roger sneezing meaning has the different
lots and different batches within a lot
all or are the same and then stable me
as it doesn't change over time so you
make a batch of reference interior
whether it's the genomic DNA that I
mentioned before or the antibody
reference material it's stable over a
specified time so that when you pull one
off the shelf you can get it similar
result over time these are used to
assess the measurement system or the
calibrator measurement
system in the difference is you might
want it to assess your measurement
system where you make a measurement on
to genomic DNA you learn the genomic a
reference material and if you get a good
result of the reference material then
that gives you confidence that you got
good result with your unknown for a
calibration process we mean you have a
device and you run me the reference
material and then you adjust the knobs
on your device to make it give you the
right answer whatever you think the
reference 20 should be delivered to
classic ways that reference materials
has been used and they're not quite a
magic bullet but a lot of people call
them a magic bullet they're one of the
most common common tools for improving
confidence and measuring the obvious is
definitely not a magic bullet but if you
want to call any of the measurements
your shirin strategies in magic bullet
that might be it it's the best one of
them all that's generally the most
commonly used one of the people when
people go to first I'm going to talk
about the reference material for
measuring lead systems are easy to
conceptualize and compared to sell
measurements to a little more picky a
little more confusing so this are an
1643 trace elements in water over on the
right there you can see that table will
all be trace elements they're measured
in this and this is a little vial of
water and it's certified for a
composition of these different elements
lead is obviously of interest do with
toxicity miss has 73 different
references materials for measuring let
you know that's quite a new testament to
is how important measuring lead
accurately is and you can see some of
the different ones right flower
certified for amount of lead solder lead
paint you can see lead paint of
different colors this is because each
one of these interferes with your
measurement measuring lead in rice flour
is not the same as measuring lead in
water the rice flour interferes with the
lead measurement so if you're going to
measure it in flour having a reference
material has been characterized the
legend flower is useful because the
artifacts that you get for measuring a
flower will be different than your
that you get from measuring it in water
so the matrix interferes and we saw the
same thing when I was talking about
cholesterol few slides back with the
different cholesterol reference
reference materials so for the
regenerative medicine feel there's been
discussion of using cells as reference
materials which you know is a tall order
I just talked about lead servo flies
back I mentioned the knit proteins there
antibody reference material now we're
talking about self lead is obviously
more simple than a protein and protein
composed of hundreds of amino acids have
post translational modifications the
structure can change there's a few
different isoforms of it with cells
you're talking about thousands of
different small molecules and proteins
and lipids and nucleic acids and all
bundled up in a membrane in the cells
may vary from one to the other so
suitability is a reference material
becomes more challenging we talked about
so remember collages and stable cells
are certainly not going to be as
homogeneous as a lead sample so that may
present challenges so use cells as a
reference to tell you need a stable and
homogeneous sorts of cells and you need
good ways to characterize themselves
which we don't really have right now air
is on cell counting are about thirty
percent right now measurements of cell
morphology can't really be done compared
Lee you might be able to get consistent
results in one lab but getting good
comparative results of self shaped and
from different labs really isn't
achievable right now fears are around
one hundred percent or more and
similarly with flow cytometry which is a
common way that solves it cares a lot
you passed around a vial of cells and do
a flow cytometry measurement you might
get an error of a hundred percent
between themselves this is an example of
some variability in a cell counting
system they compared a culture tower
which is the heated space system the
hemocytometer and one of these things
were taking pictures of cells in a flow
chain
we're in council nuclei either a buy
sell or countess in this particular
paper you can see there at that middle
range concentration there's a range of
values of about forty percent it may not
seem like a lot but if you're trying to
know the patient and your error on your
doses forty percent that is going to be
troublesome because you're trying to
achieve a positive outcome in a human
clinical trial with an experimental cell
therapy and your dose has a forty
percent error on it that uncertainty
gets propagated through the entire
clinical trial making it very difficult
to detect a significant outcome at the
end this is an example of a cell of the
reference materials issued by USP they
overcame the stability issue by
freeze-drying and fixing themselves in
this case they took cv34 positive cells
and fixed and lyophilized them they use
them in a flow cytometry measurement
where you're going to add an antibody
and do a measurement of c34 expression
and when they pass it around among 16
lab you can see there in the label there
on the bottom the red red square or
rectangle the range that you should get
its 16 to 30 for cd34 positive cells per
microliter you can see that's quite a
large range that's the range of seventy
two percent well I spoke with them and
that's a standard deviation so it's
basically 25 plus or minus nine that's
the best we can do right now the very
common cell therapies is a very common
measurement and this is a very common
epitope so this is the state of the art
for a cell measurement a range of
seventy-two percent on the measurement
so you can see we heat there's plenty of
room for improvement here to help
advance the industry and make it so that
cell therapies can become made a
reproducible and manufacturable
therapeutic
this is a really interesting slide that
a colleague of mine at NIST made it's
his name is Dave Dewar the bipm the
outfit in Paris that organizes inter
laboratory studies he went to all the
inter laboratory data that he knew of
and made this chart of the variability
in the measurement by class of
measurement so the y-axis is the
uncertainty in the x axis of the
different classes of measurement now all
the way in the left there you can see a
length measurement you can see you're
getting uncertainties with six decimal
places so that's like if you're
measuring a meter you're talking about
an air of point zero zero zero zero zero
zero 1 meter some old measuring
wavelengths of light and you know
they're getting uncertainties in many
decimal places below zero on a nanometer
for mass and temperature the next to you
can see those are all below 0 point 0 0
1 all the way on the right there you can
see biological measurements and always
done for those so far in this community
is a PPR measurement where they passed
around a standard a PPR standard and
make a measurement different labs you
can see number of measurements across
the bottom there there's been 72 length
measurements and for Lyle object
measurements and with these for pcr
measurements the errors are around one
hundred percent so you can see biologic
measurements are well behind the
physical and chemical and organic
measurements so this sort of puts in
perspective of where we are measurement
wise and why bringing cell therapy
products and biologics and market it's
hard because the measurement
infrastructure is not as mature as weak
as it needs to be make it a little more
philosophical talk about truth so when
talking about truth i found that it's
most satisfying if you just accept the
fact that you'll know anything with
absolute certainty there may be a truth
but as a mortal you can't be aware of
the truth
this again gets back to this definition
from the vocabulary international
mythology the quality intended to be
measured you don't never know for sure
what you're measuring and you can't
really ever know the truth we make our
best effort and our best estimate but we
don't know for sure which means you
could you can kind of ignore what the
truth is and think of life more as a
probability distribution function things
that you know i think you know you know
if a certain degree of certainty but you
never know them one hundred percent so
now plot down there on the bottom what
we have in our lives is the blue line
which is a dispersion or a probability
distribution function on that histogram
the red lines are true value don't know
where the true value lot it might be
right in the middle of your measurements
or it might be well off you might be way
off the ballpark you don't really know
and this is a head game you can play it
yourself take something simple that you
think you know and ask yourself how do
you know for sure that you know it so
what day is today is it februari 22nd is
a februari 23rd you may have looked at
the calendar but there could be a
misprint your phone might tell you the
day but there could be a computer glitch
your mom might have told you but maybe a
mom calendar is incorrect maybe you went
on the NIST website but maybe the NIST
website got hacked maybe you've been
tracking the days on your own on your
wall of a crayon or maybe you missed a
day no matter how sure is something you
maybe there's always a chance that
you're incorrect or that your data are
incorrect or misleading you and you know
the trump card is always you to be
elucidating so I know that's a
philosophical but it makes measurement
science more digestible if you accept
that
this is a slide from a colleague of mine
named James Sullivan admit that I've
adapted and it juxtaposes data and
expert opinion so if you have a problem
and you design an experiment you'll
collect some data and then you'll
analyze it do some statistic to try to
come up with a solution and the data are
key to making your measurement
quantitative however the expert is an
equally important part of this process
your reasoning your experience common
sense they have to be part of the
process a pile of data and statistics
can't stand alone they have to be
interpreted so the expert is in equally
important part of this process you don't
ever know the truth so it's going to be
a matter of opinion what you think the
truth is so your reasoning and
understanding and expertise is always
going to be key for any reaching any
decision which brings up another
interesting topic which is truth
selection we choose a truth what we
believe to be a truth in our measurement
and that again is based on a matter of
opinion a good example is the length
measurement you could use a ruler to
make a measurement of a millimeter or
you could use an interferometer now we
all have rulers at home when we use
rulers rulers are actually calibrated by
interferometer but the measurement
community has made it very clear and I
don't think there's much dispute in an
interferometer is a much better way to
measure a distance San a bullet more
accurate and reproducible and precise
internet / ometer you can see that
little diagram on the right there you
shine a laser and it goes through a year
where the beam gets split and it bounces
off two more mirrors and they recombine
and when the light recombine you get a
interference pattern and if you move one
of those reflecting here's a little
teensy bit that was that interference
pattern shift which makes this a very
sensitive way to measure distance you
can measure nanometers this way and in
fact many mics stage micrometer for
microscopes and rulers are calibrated
this way using a laser interferometer so
why is the laser interferometer chosen
there is no authority that can prove
definitively that interferometers are
the best way you might be able to find
exceptions where rulers better but
generally speaking experts agree that
the interferometer is a better way to go
so my point being is the reasoning and
thought and the expert opinion has to
come into the decision so reasons for
selecting the ground truth one is there
is a definitive test and this is the
case I just told you about what the
interferometer so it's widely agreed
that an interferometer it's a better way
of making a length measurement so we use
interferometer in a drug manufacturing
case the tests that are used to
characterize the clinical trial product
in the clinical trial batches that our
bank during a clinical trial or used to
assess future batches so with the cell
therapy product goes into the patient
you collect data then future batches of
cell therapy products that are
manufacturers are prepared back to that
starting batch that we're used in the
clinical trial so the clinical trial
data become the definitive the
definition of the truth for this case
but we don't have a definitive test we
may look for agreement between multiple
methods sometimes this is called
orthogonal measurement let's say you do
a web search it's often a good
recommendation to consult several
sources confirm you're fine and you
wouldn't just want to go to one website
and reach a decision if you're measuring
cell viability you might want to use two
different tests the trypan blue
exclusion which measures membrane
leakiness and an MTT assay which
measures metabolic activity that would
improve your confidence in cell
viability is a case where you don't have
a definitive method for defining what
cell viability is so using to test is
not a bad idea personal experience may
come into it you might use the
measurements at your local Amir with you
might do a web search you want to rely
rely more heavily on one website or
other because maybe you have a friend
that works there and you know they do
good work from your discussions with
that person in cell viability you might
have more experience with MTG maybe
you've been running it for ten years
you've trusted more than a trice and
blue
this is another way to treat the
selected history you may have collected
a lot of data over a long period of time
and that has become your tree you buy a
new device you might not trust it until
you get used to it might use your old
device and compare the new device to
that and then visual visual measurements
are very important than humans were very
visually oriented the term ground truth
comes from verification of satellite
imagery where people were physically set
to the ground to a particular location
to confirm what was there you know maybe
they saw a tree in the satellite image
so people are sent to the ground
visually confirm and humans we like to
see it's our favorite scent and when
you're doing a decision and you
collected data it's always got to be
absorbing absorbing it into your
conscience through your eyes is the most
common way we love to make powerpoint
slides like we're doing right now we
like grass and you like the computer
monitor we like reading hearing it's
probably second for us I'm talking to
you as well so looking and seeing touch
you know you might feel your incubator
to make sure it's on that's a little
measurement you just made metal if a
deer sees you they might look at you and
say I think I see some butt but if they
smell you they're down away from you
they'll run they'll need to see you dear
they trust their nose taste I was a
turkey hill factory where they make ice
cream in Pennsylvania and they had a
taste taster there he's there to see so
taste is there is there ground truth for
ice cream manufacturing they have
tasters and every batch that comes off
their line somebody's got a sick of
spoon and one of those who taste it and
probably know it's good so we're very
efficient absorbing a visual data and
it's convincing to us which makes
imaging very popular approach or sign
there's this cool data set if you
haven't seen it called hands comp
quartet you can see across the top there
there's four data set right there and
you have x and y and a huge plot
calculating you get the same mean 999
all the way across and the same standard
deviation
XCOM 3.32 3.32 the variances are all the
same the slope the M is the same
y-intercept is the same and the
variances that early Pearson's
correlation is the same point 82 but
when you plot them they look like
different and if you just trusted your
Pearson correlation coefficient you
could be misled and if you just stay at
the data you might be misled but when
you make these plot you can quickly see
it at the top left looks like a linear
relationship maybe the bottom left of to
the top right probably not linear in the
bottom we're sorry the bottom right
definitely not linear there's a saying
just make the damn brass when you're
analyzing your data should always make a
graph because our brains are wired to
efficiently process imagery staring at
pages of numbers might work for some
people but generally speaking making a
graph is a good idea so an inter lab
test this is an example of colleague of
mine did in the ninth nanotechnology and
the problem was they had large
variability in their measurements of
nanoparticle cytotoxicity so they took a
549 cells and the added polystyrene
nanoparticles and they measured cell
metabolism with MTX acting may get a
positive control and they did this with
several labs this is a publication if
you want to check it out initially these
are the different labs running the
different tests you can see the theory
don't always agree each plot on the left
is the optical density so higher numbers
indicates higher cell viability and
along the x axis ii of concentration of
whatever it is it's being added so you
should have it the plot should all be
dipping down to the right we don't see
that some of them actually increase as
concentration of the additive increases
which doesn't make sense and this is
what in our laboratory studies do they
take this sort of what might seem is a
simple
and through rounds of testing they work
to improve the protocol so people can
get comparable results and they can
conduct the assay in a comparable
fashion and different lab after they ran
several rounds you can see they can get
better agreement now these are some of
the plots that you can generally see
that there's more in agreement they
found that rinsing step was a problem
because people were rinsing differently
and it was washing selves off plates
another one is the nano particles
themselves and they were adding them to
the cells or interfering with a plate
reader measurement and a number of issue
was there pipetting accuracy they made
these thing called an issue calla
diagram which is the catalog of all the
sources of variability it was invented
in the 60s at a shipyard in Kawasaki by
Carol Ishikawa most generally used to
improve men and management of a
manufacturing process but it works
equally well for a measurement process
you can see I've highlighted the things
that mentioned on the other page is that
the pipetting and the nano particle
interference and the rinsing steps
turned out to be the most troublesome
and cause the most variability in there
a thing they came up with this
specification in these control each one
of these different Wells is a different
control or they have different amounts
of the different controls and particles
the outer wells are just medium that's
the control for evaporation the they
have a Wells there that air control
number one which is just the particles
only they had to control with particles
and sell the cadmium sulfate particles
themselves mentally should get a
reproducible self cell killing event
they have a one with just sells only you
can get a reading what cells are going
to give you without any nanoparticles
present control for is no cells and no
treatment so that's just your background
for your ass a control five is the test
substance only so in their case it was a
type of nanoparticle that's always going
to give you some interfere
in your ass then you're talking about
particles control six was just a buffer
and then control seven and eight where
other ones with just sells only and then
over the right there you can see the
athlete specifications that they found
Sol with just the cadmium sulfate you
should get a target optical density of
point 06 and then just the cadmium
sulfate added to the cell you should get
an inhibitory concentration of 77 micro
moles per liter and then just the cells
only without anything at it should give
you an optical density of two this is an
example of how an air laboratory tests
can help you to determine specifications
and when one of these gets written up
into a documentary standards you can
start in your own lab by following this
process all right my final topic is a
measure and chart this is a measurement
assurance tool and it helps you sort
through assumptions that are being made
in your measurement it enables each
measure an to be identified and accept
and helps you determine if you're
measuring what you think you're
measuring it helps you to determine
whether or not your measurement
validation your biological relevance or
the same thing and i'll get to that back
to that so for this particular example
we are measuring the amount of cells
here on a substrate of substrate and in
this measurement process you would see
12 on a substrate culture them remove
the medium after seven days and at a
digestion solution incubated overnight
transfer some of your life eight to a
new plate add some of the pico green
reagent which measures DNA incubate it
and then read the fluorescent light
reader and then analyze your data and
determine your test result and if you
have any good substrate facilities you
might get a good high signal with equal
green which would indicate the adhesions
however if you break this down it can
help you into trouble shooting this
athlete because you can see each of the
assumptions that's being made the number
of pecos all the way in the left a
number of people green molecules down to
DNA is the basic of the measurement when
you life's excels in releasing the DNA
and assuming that the amount of DNA is
proportionate of cell number you add the
pico green which binds to the DNA and
fluorescence you also might be measure
the number of protons admitted on your
plate reader you are also measuring the
fluorescence intensity which is going to
come out of your plate years you're
assuming that your fluorescence
intensity is proportional to the amount
of DNA and you're assuming that the
amount of DNA is proportional to the
number of cells and you're assuming that
that is related to the ability of your
substrate to support cell adhesion over
on the right there the ability of the
substrate to support sell these and
that's what's most important that's what
you're trying to investigate that's your
measure in because that's what you want
to make a decision about is why up a
good substrate fidelity but all these
different steps all these
proportionality is all these different
assumptions make it hard to know if
that's what you're really measuring and
making the sort of chart for a
biological Mel of measurement can be
very informative you can see what can go
wrong and screw you up for instance the
sequence of the DNA can infect finding
all the way on the left there discussing
the issues not all the DNA may be
accessible maybe I didn't like the cells
up quite well enough there could be a
lot of particular particulate in your
whites eight which is interfering with
the detection the cells can be defining
at a very high rate which means the DNA
that cell number ratio might not be
constant so when you have a lot of salt
dividing you're going to get end up
having a little extra DNA in there and
you make could might lose a lot of self
during your handling so all these
different things to confound your
measurement you might lead to
variability and make it hard for you to
determine if you actually determine
whether you have a good cell adhesion
substrate so these these flow diagrams
can help you figure out what your
assumptions are especially with a
biological measurement which is not not
always straightforward so in closing
there are many measurement assurance
strategies to enhance confidence in your
data enhance comparability of your data
and make your data more quantitative
noli's can help you to make better
decisions so thanks to your attention
thanks to Dave doing marks out for a lot
of input and my contact information is
there if anyone
to contact me thank you
thank you dr. Simon for that informative
presentation now before we get started
on the question and answer session I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit them by
typing them in the Q&A box which again
can be found by clicking on the green
Q&A button up lower left of your
presentation window now it's how to get
to as many questions as we can but if we
are unable to get your question due to
time constraints dr. kind and will be
answering questions via email following
the presentation now our first question
is from the finest why are there so many
standards development organizations why
can't they unite to make it easier to
follow so the dinners development
organization self-organized there's no
authority to organize them and they come
together from stakeholder communities
and they arise organically it would be
like asking why there are many different
car manufacturers why do we need so many
why don't we just have one so these
different standards development
organizations arise in different feel to
serve their stakeholder community I know
there's we work very hard and
regenerative medicine to try to stay
informed of what's happening I have many
colleagues in my group that are active
in other organizations and we give each
other updates I pay attention to all the
emails from the others other groups in
the summary so I can stay informed as I
mentioned the fact in the ISO and the
bipm I try to keep an eye on all those I
may not be as active in them but we try
to keep an eye on what's going on to
avoid overlap and then when we see
overlap we talk and figure out how to
work together so I hope that answers
your question
Jack assignment we have a few audience
members to program in so have written in
asking how they can get involved with
standards development well each each
organization has its own policy at ASTM
I can talk about anyone can join ASTM
and participate in a working group the
fee to join is 75 bucks and all the
committee's are open you can join right
now so if you have an idea for a
standard or you see a standard on the
website that you'd like to contribute to
your welcome so you could get in touch
with me if you want more information or
you can contract the the best thing to
do would be to look on the ASTM website
see what standards would be of interest
to you and join one of those groups and
again their voluntary they need every
two years sorry twice a year in May in
November the one I go to FF 04 I mean
it's a two-day meeting and they have a
webex so you don't have to travel we've
had people do standards from afar where
the whole standard was developed and
written and balloted without coming to a
meeting so that's also possible it's not
as easy it's a lot easier when you can
interact if your colleagues but it's
possible so I would welcome you to get
involved if you're interested thank you
dr. Simonson that information now we
have time for one last question when
will regenerative medicine become a
yellow
well it depends where you ask as I
mentioned before there the Alliance
regenerative medicine survey says
there's already 30 return of medicine
products on the market I mentioned
living skin equivalents and the
articular cartilage was a most widely
used in some of the older one when will
it become more effective many like in
their regenerative medicine is industry
to protein therapeutics insulin was
first given to patients in the 20s but
the recombinant protein therapeutic
insulin was not approved or marketed
until nineteen eighty those quite as
quite a long time to develop the
measurement infrastructure to make it a
reproducible viable industry right now
2017 the protein therapeutics I think
last year they accounted for one quarter
of new drug approvals and they're
considered the fastest growing segment
of the market so you know it's been
nearly a hundred years since 1920s will
it take that long to cell therapy who
knows I would certainly say that there's
were poised for growth in the next 20 10
to 20 years and you know coming from
this course I believe that having
improved measurement infrastructure is
going to be key to that so thanks for
that question
have a by 2 once again thank God for
cross lineman first presentation deck
assignment you have any final comments
for our audience thanks to this
opportunity I hope you found it useful
if you have any questions or comments
for me please get in touch thank you
that's assignment i would also like to
thank our sponsors lab group for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing from a 20-second 2017
you will receive an email from leverage
over ting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
form an announcement to your colleagues
who may have missed today's live events
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you next time goodbye
you